Nobody’s perfect, and everybody makes mistakes-
especially on the job.
But when you do your work with the knowledge
that it could be scrutinized by millions of
people, it’s important to make sure you
can stand behind it 100%.
Sometimes despite everyone’s best efforts,
tiny mistakes slip through the cracks.
And once you know them, they cannot be unseen.
These are Screen Rant’s 10 Disney Movie
Mistakes That Slipped Past You.
The Jungle Book
The live-action 2016 remake of Disney classic
The Jungle Book is made of pure hollywood
magic- also known as CGI.
The story follows Mowgli, a young boy raised
by animals in the jungle.
And since we haven’t figured out how to
train real animals to speak English, computer
generated ones take their place.
Director Jon Favreau has stated that his focus
was always on the realism of the animals.
And for the most part, he succeeds.
But when the majority of audience members
found themselves wrapped up in the action,
a few began to wonder something simple: how
come the raindrops don’t splash off the
characters?
Star Wars: The Force Awakens
It is very possible that the films in the
Star Wars franchise are the most scrutinized
on Earth.
The space opera has an intensely loyal fanbase,
but that doesn't mean they won’t notice
the plethora of continuity errors in 2015’s
The Force Awakens.
While a lot of the goofs are tiny and wardrobe-related,
there is one instance that’s hard to overlook.
In the intense interrogation scene with Kylo
Ren, very visible tears roll down Rey’s
face.
But when the camera changes angles, they’re
completely gone.
If you missed it the first time around, we
don’t blame you- it’s a pretty powerful
moment in the film.
But now that you know, keep your eyes out
for it.
Finding Dory
Octopuses are super smart, they have three
hearts, and they’re one of the oldest living
species on the planet.
It’s no wonder why the people behind Finding
Dory would want to include one in their movie.
And while he’s technically the same species,
Hank refers to himself as a “septapus”
instead, because he only has seven arms.
Except… that’s not really possible.
Because another thing that makes octopuses
cool is their real-life ability to regenerate
lost limbs.
Looks like Hank’s gonna have to find another
way to stand out from the crowd.
Wreck It Ralph
Computer animation is a beautiful thing, and
Disney continues to be a pioneer in the field.
In 2012, they took the opportunity to show
off a little with Wreck-It Ralph.
If you’ve ever wondered what the characters
inside video games do after the arcade closes,
this is the movie for you.
Packed with cameos, the film shows Ralph interacting
with characters from a few different franchises.
But when he finds out that the ones from his
own game are celebrating without him, he takes
it out on the cake.
Except, there isn’t actually any cake anywhere.
Sure, we see the icing go flying.
But shouldn’t there be some cake with it
too?
Cinderella
Let’s be honest, we’ve all dreamed of
having a Fairy Godmother.
The thought of a sweet old lady showing up
and fixing all the world’s problems is a
nice one, however far-fetched.
Of course, the most notorious Fairy Godmother
is Cinderella’s.
After living way too long under the rule of
her heinous stepmother, Cinderella catches
herself a husband at the Royal Ball.
The dresses worn by Disney princesses are
always iconic, and Cinderella’s is no exception.
But if you take a closer look, you’ll notice
that the wedding dresses don't exactly match
up.
Income frames it has long sleeves, but in
others it’s short with long gloves.
Given how many kids grow up using this movie
as inspiration for their future weddings,
this could be a very important detail.
Beauty and the Beast
You’ve heard the stories.
No one’s slick as Gaston.
No one’s quick as Gaston.
And in a spitting match, nobody spits like
Gaston.
Yet, despite all this, Belle from 1991’s
Beauty and the Beast does not want to marry
Gaston.
He chases her around the house after his failed
proposal, but falls through the doorway and
into the mud.
Both when he enters and exits the house, the
door opens to the outside.
But when it cuts back to show Belle placing
his boots outside, it’s clearly opened inward.
Given that an entire team of people were responsible
for the animation, it’s surprising to see
this interruption to the continuity of the
scene.
Tron: Legacy
A movie anchored in the world of video games
has a lot to work with, and 2010’s Tron:
Legacy has even more going for it.
Being a sequel to the 1982 original, Legacy
had a built-in fanbase.
With original actors returning to reprise
their roles, Daft Punk signed on to do the
music, and 21st century graphics, the film
had something for everyone… including gaming
historians.
As Flynn walks through an arcade that had
supposedly been locked up in 1989, some eagle-eyed
viewers spotted Mortal Kombat.
And while that may not seem like a big deal,
it’s actually a pretty glaring oversight-
since that title wasn't released until 1992.
Three years after the arcade closed.
Given its intense focus on gaming, we’re
surprised this one slipped through the movie’s
cracks.
Inside Out
In 2015 Disney and Pixar set out to illuminate
the inner workings of a young girl’s mind,
and the result is amazing.
Inside Out tells the story of Riley, a kid
learning to cope after her family moves to
San Francisco.
Thankfully, she has some very well-intentioned
emotions to guide her along the way.
But it wouldn’t be a Disney movie if there
wasn’t some heartbreaking tension.
And as two of the characters try to intervene,
they find themselves in need of a shortcut.
After Boing Boing incorrectly interprets the
danger sign as saying “shortcut”, Joy
and Sadness follow him.
But at a different point in the movie, Sadness
talks about having read some manuals.
So, if she can read, why didn’t she say
anything about the sign?
WALL-E
In a scary vision of the future where humans
have abandoned earth, one little robot named
WALL-E works to pick up the garbage.
He also falls in love with a lady robot named
EVE and, through an interesting twist of fate,
ends up in space.
The whole thing is actually pretty adorable,
and even has the show tunes to match.
But it’s not perfect.
One scene where WALL-E is flying through space
shows the stars twinkling in the background.
While the effect adds some whimsy, it’s
not scientifically sound.
Stars appear to twinkle in the night sky because
of changes in the earth’s atmosphere.
But if we were to look at them from space,
in the absence of any atmosphere, their light
would remain constant.
Frozen
It’s not easy to write a song, never mind
writing a song fit for a Disney princess.
But for years, the company has been churning
out musical after musical and finding only
success.
Their soundtracks have always been strong
sellers, but in 2013 audiences lost their
collective mind with the release of Frozen.
Quickly reaching the top of the charts, the
soundtrack was full of original music.
It was so popular that even people who hadn’t
seen the movie knew all the words to “Let
It Go”.
And while the tune may be catchy, it’s not
exactly accurate.
The movie is set in the 17th century, but
the song references the word “fractals”
which wasn’t utilized until 1975.
If you think that’s a little nit-picky,
feel free to let it go.
What do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other Disney mistakes?
Tell us about them in the comments, and subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more videos like
this one.